if you're like me you watch this latest
episode and were like wait what's going
on yes it wouldn't be an episode of the
changeling without throwing in an entire
dream episode that'll have you
questioning everything fret not we're
going to try to unlock some of the
episode's biggest questions and theorize
what's really going on keep in mind I
haven't read the book so there won't be
any spoilers and I've left timestamps
below to all the topics I'll be covering
now let's get into it a lot of you may
be wondering what the hell was going on
in this episode and don't worry I had to
watch it a few times because it can be
quite confusing essentially we have
older lilan reliving the night younger
Lillian killed her husband Brian where
every character is played by someone
we've seen in the first six episodes the
narrator States we cast our dreams as a
play which implies what we're seeing
here is a dream a dream of a past event
it also explains why these roles are
filled from people we've already seen
Lester the hotel manager we saw as
Lillian's boss the two guys in the
hallway were a part of Apollo's single
dad's group at the Park Brian plays an
AIDS victim The Prostitute was the woman
from Apollo support group the John of
course was William and the woman with
the baby outside was Emma's sister so
even though we see older Lillian
attempting to call Apollo with her cell
phone the setting here is actually New
York 1982 we're at the elk Hotel an app
name considering it's an animal called
the king of the forest in Norway the
hotel's original purpose was to serve
immigrants coming from overseas
interesting since the first shot of the
series was about immigrants coming from
overseas and this episode follows a
literal immigrant who came from overseas
Lillian has come to commit suicide after
killing her husband Brian who we see
attempting to drown four-year-old Apollo
in the bath he became suspicious of
Lilian cheating after finding a receipt
for a one night stay at the hotel this
same receipt we'll see in Brian's impr
probia box in episode 1 at the end of
the episode we'll see an entry in the
guest book from 1977 the year baby Brian
was conceived with two familiar names
Lillian and her boss char Char Blackwood
welcome to leic Weiss and Blackwood
that's me in an act of poetic irony
lilan wants to off herself in the same
room Apollo was conceived but I still
have so many questions how did Lillian
get these bruises if Brian was already
dead did Brian survive the whack To The
Head and the two of them have a fight
and if Brian is dead how did the impr
probia Box wind up on their doorstep
years later a box which contains items
like the hotel receipt I'm sure lilan
wouldn't want lying around the narrator
also tells us that lilan will hold a
dying man three times so just who
exactly are these three men the first
has got to be her brother Arthur who was
shot while fleeing the dictatorship in
Uganda number two could be Brian if we
are to believe that he's dead and three
might be the AIDS victim or a yet
unknown third person one of lilian's
lines I thought was really interesting
was her saying I would kill to be an
American then at the end of the episode
we hear her saying she finally feels
American which I kind of took to mean
she's killed Lillian has also brought
brought with her a tape recorder maybe
it's her version of a suicide note
something to leave behind for Apollo
once she's gone lilan has come back to
the elk hotel to quote unmake a deal in
exchange for getting away with murder
and allowing her to raise her child it
looks as though a price must be paid and
that price at least it's implied is the
life of her grandchild so she has come
back to unmake this deal perhaps that's
why we see old dillian back at the very
spot she dropped her husband's body in
that suitcase maybe if she retrieves the
luggage and admits to her husband's
murder it could bring baby Brian back
but who exactly did she make this deal
with my guess God she basically went
from not believing in God to believing
in him it kind of felt to me like one of
those situations where you're like God
if you help me through this I promise to
go to church every Sunday the contents
of the suitcase are still unknown but
it's heavily implied that this is where
lilan stored Brian's Body Lester the
hotel manager also tells the John that
if he shoots him he'll find his body
quote stuffed in a suitcase at the
bottom of a river we never find find out
how Brian got a hold of this receipt why
would lilan keep this around the
apartment in one of their fights Brian
says to Lillian you all glamour Lan you
only appear as you wish to be seen
glamour was the term Cal used to refer
to the magic that alters one's
appearance and it's pretty ironic lilan
worked at a glamour slm modeling agency
now I'm not going to talk about all the
quotes we see on the hotel table ones
that we've seen littered throughout the
series but there's one in particular I'd
like to discuss it's the one Lillian
writes down on the hotel table if you're
looking for a sign this is it this same
line was seen last episode where Wheels
lives and is also a signed Lilian sees
before heading into the hotel Lillian
talks about wishing she had seen the
signs of Brian's Insanity earlier so
maybe this is her way of passing it on
of sending a warning to others who might
be in a similar position some of you may
have noticed that the intro credits
changeed slightly from episode to
episode with this installment including
a cryptic Tex stating North southeast
west where is baby Brian's Nest
unfortunately we don't get get any
updates on Apollo or Emma's story this
episode but it looks like the finale
will be converging on this so-called
Nest at the end we travel back to the
elk hotel which I can only assume is
present day the place is completely
abandoned but the table in the back has
been etched with the first passage found
in the book The Changeling reiterating
that this is indeed a fairy tale we see
leftover gold sequins symbolizing
Lillian's dream of being a singer and of
course we can't forget the guest book
showing the 1977 night where Apollo was
conceived with lilian's boss but now I
turn it over to you what did you think
of the second last episode I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
please be sure to like And subscribe and
for more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram @ thinkstory YT
until next time remember wait what's
going
on